hi folks maximum McGee here and today
I'm sitting down with Phillip Asher from
Trinity entertainment and together we're
gonna take a look at a little game
called dungeon defenders to Phillip yeah
thanks for sitting down with me thank
you so why don't you go ahead and set up
for those who aren't familiar what
dungeon defenders to is all about so
dungeon defenders to is a tower defense
action role-playing game diablo but plus
tower offense and third person sounds
great let's go ahead and jump right in
and get straight into the action so
let's see so we're going to show off a
couple maps today but the first one
we're going to take a look at is
actually called siphon site d okeydoke
it's a one of our happier maps basically
there's siphon sites normally are right
i think so can see all the happy colors
one of the big things in Dungeon
Defenders to is our art style we're
going for this very hand-painted look
and kind of take a look at everything
all of our visual effects are drawn in
2d so you kind of look at our water it's
very different much it's machine over
the box right that's one of my favorites
everything yeah if I remember the
original dungeon defenders correctly it
was sort of an interesting mash of
different genres and styles like you had
a little bit of tower defense he had a
little bit of action RPG like what you
were saying with the get hablo elements
yep and this game is the same we're
gonna show some of that now so basically
the core of the game is that they're bad
guys that come out of all these spawn
points here there are starting to look
at them you can see this one and we can
see the little trails coming off of them
indicating yeah but the roots they're
going to be taking to the level exactly
in order to stop them you want to place
the fences down in order to get in their
way so we're going to do but first we're
going to show you how you can make
defenses be really cool by combining
them together okay so we're going to
cheat a little bit to spawn some enemies
so right now I placed a huntress kaiser
trap oh here's our trap that was this a
new trap for this is a new trap yep yep
mostly shafts are you actually hollow
defenses and other monk over here is
going to place a lightning or sliding or
is actually returning from the previous
game the interesting thing monk hello
explain the monkeys were easily stinking
to use my ping to impale
seriously though mom hey here we go we
just needed a good impaired I like a
lightning or over here is that the monks
not listening to me all right let me
type to him sorry well we'll edit this
part out don't be very slow area okay
all right once he gets the lightning
thing down sweet all right there we go
now we got a new alien awesome okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
spawn an orc over here you're gonna see
that after the orc gets wet when it gets
hit by lightning damage it will actually
get electrocuted so now all the
different classes have to work together
in order to keep the enemies back okay
so sort of the elemental properties of
your traps will sort of play off each
other yep so you can see the work sweat
and now he likes me now if there had
been a fire trap there instead of a
lightning trapper to do less damage
because you get ready what exactly we do
less damage and they wouldn't get dealt
it wouldn't have this done and obviously
in a tower defense game stunning is very
important because it stops them from
progressing down until these guys like
with me I can actually show you though
actually let's just set up on this guy
instead of killing him I'll place a up
Nova looks like he's gonna divert can
summon another one alright so this is
our napalm balloon although the design
game tells me it's called the blaze
balloon not my preferred name but uh so
this actually does fired go to
liberation ya gotta give them them it is
good alliteration I will give the
ranking fall for that so wait for the
balloon to respawn and then I can
actually hear here we go okay so i can
oil these guys up there I guess yeah you
can lower and then I'll shoot this so
they get split on AO and then they
totally burst into flames yep
that's one of the many new features and
hundred defenders to a lot more strategy
and kind of setting up your defenses
with your other friends that also seems
like a very easy way to help communicate
how towers work together for the player
exactly instead of just arbitrarily like
oh the laser tower of course it
interacts with this other type of tower
because of Morse lasers and rocks go
together you'd be surprised how many
times we have to talk to our designers
into that guy's that makes sense like
waiting yeah nobody's going to know that
a laser in a rock go together this way
exact water and lightning makes much
more sense mm-hmm we have these things
integrated entire world as well for
example here's a water traffic and push
enemies off the map oh is that something
that's on like a cool down timer yep
it's only cool down timer so now a 24
seconds to activate it again and it's
right there on the tram yep alright
let's actually we're gonna leave this
map we're gonna go to a late game map
okay alright sweet so here we are at the
new map so this is a late game map you
can actually look at the mini-map in the
corner and see that there's two main
objectives here we have to defend ok and
then further down the lane over here
there's this one some objective which if
it falls we won't lose the map but we
are gonna have to face a lane that's
basically right in front of our
objective might not be so much fun one
thing before we store before you start
that I'll take a look at really quick is
all of our levels and dungeon defenders
to actually connect so you can see like
over here is the castle which the sewer
level that we were just on this below so
you can sort of track your progress and
you see how far you've come exactly and
down here is a village level that we
have and if you look over here this
giant epic temple yeah that's sort of
where you're headed yeah is that always
can you always sort of see that in the
distance yeah so you could always see
everything
yeah everything makes sense I believe I
like that I like that along I do too i'm
like congratulation artists i know
having worlds make sense so often that's
not something in half a it well yes if
you play the first dungeon defenders
thank you about halfway through till you
realize you've been the same castle this
is wearing my own castle it is so let's
see we can look at basically okay we're
gonna look at what guys are coming out
of each lane and then we're gonna play
stuff to stop them yeah so it gives you
a little preview here of the type you
have enemies of your face so you can see
so I think guys uh maybe want to do the
electric combo in this Lane I'll play
some guys are traps and then I think
I'll actually switch to the apprentice I
have to show off some of them too now I
forget are your traps and vulnerable at
all yeah so each character has different
kinds of defenses and they do different
things the hunters traps have a reset
number okay so we can actually see I'll
place an explosive trap here cap
actually has 136 resets so once and then
it's spent yep and then it's spent and
it goes away on the other hand towers
like this have an HP bar ok what's the
enemy's attacking it guys yep alas poor
sean were made he is our elemental
character there's lots of cool towers
that work with the combo system which we
should so gonna build soon so you get
some mana one of the new things we
haven't done in two defenders to is also
this anti griefing measure which is
chest and keys so you basically get two
keys at the beginning of each wave and
you can use that to get resources to
build your defenses then if you want you
can drop that mana for other people to
build stuff I knew you said that was a
anti griefing matron yep because you
don't want one person to run around and
get all oh and they're just picking up
all the check I just know exactly and
you're like why I want to do something
so yeah other people want to play the
game too all right so can we how do you
guys think we are in the set up to it
maybe some stuff over here and kick off
the round
actually let's let's take a look at some
of the enemy's first before we get into
the thick of it just really quickly I'm
going to have Brad come over here and
spawn some enemy so he can let people
know the kinds of stuff we're going to
be facing gonna do it high speed the
spawn and kill him spawn kill him
alright so first thing we're gonna look
at his javelin thrower this is a new
enemy in the sequel and this guy is
interesting because he's a long-range
guy so it actually throws a spear that
pierced us through all of your defenses
and he's gonna send pretty far back can
it hit multiple targets yes we could hit
multiple targets and it can hit you if
you're standing behind them okay so it
kind of ruins the traditional strategy
of place a small little group of things
and they're okay then that's really
would have a lot of the enemies that
we've designed in TD to have been this
guy which is our wither bug he actually
runs up in burrows in the ground if you
let him get into the ground which is
gonna do right now yeah he sets up this
aura I was with debuff all towers and he
also you know really fun and heals
himself while you're attacking him so
he's a lot harder to that so once you
get you again yes much harder to get in
exactly so if you see that guy you want
to like prioritize him among the crowds
all right we also have this enemy tier
system we're gonna show off really
quickly so we have normal way friends
these guys are you know just normal to
beat their little annoying cuz they fly
around and shoot stuff sure there you
can pretty much handle them let's see
here pretty easy but then also if you
see coming out of land there might also
be flame women it's playing with brains
those are our tier two guys you can see
these guys are much harder to take out
you can see you don't really want to
fight it good before these things and
true to his name his back is very much
yep
alright I think we're pretty well
fortified so everyone readies up we can
kick off around I'm going to take the
river alone hi Pat you can also see in
Dungeon Defenders two upgrades actually
make things look differently ok so i
upgraded that so it's a little bit more
powerful now see if you can withstand
this wave all right now the fun begins
now is it for player maximum I'm get
Blair yep poor player maximum oh so you
can see the apprentices right-click is
actually an area with those guys are wet
so if i use my he's learning ability yep
they not only get spun up in the air but
they also get stunned and dogs howling
oh no guys really we didn't go out about
the airs not the fun that this is this
is classic for me anybody like what play
these games i always forget and then I
kick myself and then there's a couple of
restarts involves and exactly but you
know we always say in the office the
game is actually most fun when you lose
the level once me like god damn it I
can't with you but I let that happen
yeah and you never let it happen again
but that was fun all right well you
learn more in failure you do know here
in success can we have some people come
yeah build some stuff here let's gather
getting through
goodness now is this all this is just
like opening wave I assume there's going
to be a bit of a pre at some point well
in the next build face if we build stuff
right though we might be able to save
ourselves from the trouble we've created
by guys going for it yeah oh so there's
one of those those Berlin enemies that
we saw earlier it's a fantastic little
gal of animation he's got going on today
he looks so happy it's just like taking
up one of the things that our animators
have been really focused on is just
adding personality into the enemies yeah
oh crap see this guy's like just wasting
the electric or on him he's healing just
as much as just as my dad's together in
the gym can actually upgrade this so we
receive some of his health back alright
sweet alright so we survived the first
wave congratulate but of course we
accidentally let the sub objective fall
so now we're gonna have to deal with
this new Lane so we can actually maybe
bring some defenses back here see 425
this area
so you mentioned how when you upgrade
like we saw when you upgrade your
barricade earlier they actually change
style visually can you talk about some
of the other changes from the original
dungeon defender that you guys have
worked into the sequel yeah so actually
all first if we can get the square to
come here in place Squire down me we
could put that in so there are a lot of
a lot of changes from the first game we
talked about one of the first ones which
is the fact that there's a ability
resource and defense resources new game
now so let's just do both and that's you
know some of the fun and placing a guy
being able to place a geyser trap but
also use my cyclone ability and I'll
have to worry about taking this from the
same resource for another change that
we've put in is there's a lot of changes
to the loot system which we're actually
just looking at right now again so we
can look here not only is it much
cleaner but now there's actually a relic
system in addition to the armor system
that was in the first game so you know
we can take a look over here this little
amulet this is actually an amulet that
goes into my my body socket and the
reason why it's an animal is because it
doesn't show visually on my character
okay so that way makes sense the things
that you're picking up and you can
actually really focus your character and
dungeon defenders to in more varied ways
and you could in the first game like we
can see the staff over here it gets rid
of hero damage and defense power and
defense speed but actually really really
increases my tornado ability okay so you
can specialize exactly lot more in one
particular area yep and we can see what
other kind of gear i can get up if I if
I get enough tornado I can have a
tornado that's powerful enough oh man
this is possible into I'll do this I can
actually send it across the entire map
so really change is kind of how you play
the game alright another another change
in our loot system is actually that
there are rarities now so the first game
there's a pretty linear progression
through all the loot gear I'm actually
reading up guys if you're ready to fight
this this next wave I'll create this
quiet on me a little bit but in this
scheme there's actually very so there's
powerful there's epic there's a
difficult in their legendary and so that
does progress with your levels like you
can find level 20 s of each in level
threes of each both in your level you
kind of have that reward loop where you
like oh man yes I got a legendary I got
a mythical yeah you don't have to wait
until the absolute end of the gay
exactly get the one thing that yeah
esting stuff and of course you know
they're all be interesting things spread
throughout so we cannot check out how
good my lightning ability is now that i
got plus 12 we also actually have a lot
of defenses in the second game that you
can interact with for example the squire
domi that that he builds over here oh no
hurry hurry yeah I notice the I'll point
it out in the next time you're up there
but there's like that great little
statue next to that that chest were you
have to warn from oh yeah they also look
like something get interactive yep it is
so that's actually one of our
environmental traps like the water trap
that we showed up it's actually
someone's ancient energy to take out
these guys
so you can see how it's just tornadoes
and lightning storms and torrents of
water going every which one is I i
notice you guys have a pretty even split
of the four different character types is
that mandatory or can you have like if i
wanted to just have four wizards like
you decide if you want to have for
wizards you're gonna have four wizards
in fact one of the new features in the
second game as well is that you can
bring three different character classes
into battle okay and the first game we
could bring unlimited we've kind of
created a problem because you could have
the best of everything so in this game
you come with all men these wither bugs
dug in and it's destroying everything
but in this game you can only pick three
but it can be three of an apprentice if
you want you could have an apprentice
focused on tornado you could have an
apprentice focus on defenses you have an
apprentice focus on you know his attack
damage and then you could bring all
three into battle and so many of them
build different defenses with them
create this
got it and then if I don't have any
buddies sadly to come into my game with
me are there AI supports and I came
along ah there's unfortunately not a s
supports but you will be able to play by
yourself it like scale yeah a few human
people okay alright sweet so we got past
wave 2 and now 2 a 3 I think we're
actually ready to kick it off guess I'll
place a couple more defenses and upgrade
so stuff
gotta pick up all the loot I know you
get that sweet boom yeah we actually
just got loot into the game two months
ago so it makes the play completely
different gone it's just the
satisfaction of killing enemies but now
you know you get people running for
their forage and I like hold on I got
sort through everything guys you
mentioned uh like the different chest
everybody you know not having to share
the same hoop I'll can I can I trade
items that I collect with other players
so we actually games in pre-alpha right
now in our current build you can't trade
things with people but yes so that's
something that's only large that's on
the white board of New Jersey like that
is on the required list features now I
don't know about you know something as
risky as an auction house ooh and Emily
that's not even let's not even talk
about that but definitely the ability to
trade trade gear with friends will
happen hi guys we're not doing a good
job defending this lower group breaking
through yeah they are pushing center
lane on you guys pretty hard right now
yeah you guys got the top keep talking
to people that are on the internet and
ends up not doing
these wither bugs once they burrow and
make everything so weak that guys can
break through really easily yeah I've
been seeing them actually front lines
constantly yeah they were much faster
than everybody else so they can always
kind of run-in oh I got a mythical drop
it's like now that's when the patient's
essence you kind of want to go look at
it I want to know look at some numbers
were quick you guys got this right I'm
gonna be over here just checking out but
then you also don't please oh man these
guys were through that's what happens
when you picking a mystery oh no one's
the long destroyed
I have that map awareness so important
it looks like your monk did go down but
now he's a hack oh crap didn't even see
these guys over here when the Helena and
requires every time yeah now I got a lot
of simply the worse
I definitely gotta rebuild some stuff
down here we're not going to fall
completely they basically destroyed
every last defense down here but there
are a lot but we are rebuilding there's
only two left there are a lot of gems
which is good since you can use those to
rebuild it but are also the green the
green gems are tied i see ya so they're
tied down what you can build and now
finally since there's no more enemy if
you can we get plus 8 to tornado alright
so now actually we can run over thar
forge can you guys reset up the bottom
I'm gonna go check out the for equipping
and then we can start the next wave so
this wave actually if we we take a look
at our this is our tire of you here it's
a little messy in pre-alpha but it shows
you all the details of the defense see
this needs to be upgraded some showing
you range areas of effect yeah it also
shows you what enemies are coming out
like before you see our first mini boss
actually the ogre is coming out of the
gate here so I'm gonna have to hope we
have because he has a little ! er yes
the ! Ermine's pay attention heads up
yep they're below this way watch out I
notice you have two keys I do have two
keys so that's part of the anti griefing
measures we talked about earlier the
chest to get the resources here actually
uses up one of my keys ok so the chests
are actually instance just like mama but
I can't open all of my chest every way
so let's take a look at some of the
flute don't want to use hate anything
that sacrifices tornado you play some
flame towers up here
there's a new airway of there so we saw
a little bit of the the Huntress earlier
now we're seeing the wizard you want to
talk a little bit about the the other
two classes yeah we can actually switch
let's see who I haven't here so this is
the forge this is where you get to equip
a loom it's a very temporary are you I
right now but see you can see what we
have so actually I will swap to the
squire so squire is our tank class he
actually builds the really beefy stuff
that people can't get past this is
pretty great cuz I remember the squire
in the previous game he always didn't
have any pants exactly he had cards
heart boxer shorts and now he's got a
heart yeah undershirt on the first game
we had no pants available but I pants on
but now he has a heart heart shirt and
and what schools you can also see you
can see some of the loot that we have in
the game and how it customizes on your
hair like we have a nice crab shooter
here poor large oversized crab alright
let's see I'll play some and then if I
remember correctly the monk class was
sort of he was like all about auras yep
because an area of effects the monk
classes our support class hears about or
as an area of the facts and we've
changed the way his stuff looks a little
bit no longer is that the giant
mushrooms in the sky but you can see
they're here you can see their areas on
the ground right now he's placing a
lightning or actually also has a boost
or placed somewhere around here we're
trying a lot to make the monk more of a
support class than he was in the first
game so what usually happened with the
monk class in the previous game like did
people usually playing in a melee style
so yeah what usually happen is people
end up wanting to do melee attacks as
opposed to range tax because he had a
really good dps and they used him for
damage from his lightning aura or other
defenses so and they also used in the
slow enemy so this time we're actually
giving him a lot of Defense's which
directly support other heroes and
abilities a one example is he as chief
last which is offensive in that its
force push it actually pushes enemies
off of a map or awful could you put yet
could you push them off of a Ledge yep
you can push them off the ledge or you
can actually push them back into traps
so it's really fun to kind of create a
Rube Goldberg machine maybe their traps
split them up in the air and the
Cannonball knocks impact and you knock
them back more than go back up in the
air and that sort of thing he's really
good at but he also has stuff like this
boost aura which is placed somewhere
around here you
see the little particle effects coming
off of these defenses and it's actually
making them all stronger here's his
boost aura to actually upgrade this to
make it help everything even more guys
ready we have enough air defense this
time I don't know if I trust our air
defense so go play some stuff up here
there's also all these like little pool
in lips and crannies where you can place
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't have thought
to try to weasel in some towers up the
top of these columns well why not once
you figure it out your place and stuff
on tops of trees this is everywhere
anywhere is good alright we got 19
seconds to start until the month it's
ready you kind of one of the really nice
improvements we made to loot this time
around as you can see beam sticking up
in the sky or the loot is so you can 100
you can see yeah there's like a faint
little indicator like yep something over
here exactly so instead of scanning your
mini-map you know looking at the
thousands of dots different little
colored dots everywhere yep you can just
kind of scan the sky really propane see
if there's something good alright
so I'm going to try to focus on
repairing and maintaining these powers
in the middle / I know on over pair your
turret pretty too oh damn it too late
did a lot of you nice is a 0 a stun I
know it seems like AoE is definitely a
big part of the dungeon defenders
experience it seems like you're always
just wading into massive hordes of
enemies yep that's actually I mean
that's a core part of the dungeon
defenders experience from its core
review versus a ton of other guys
there's guys coming around back here I
did see I was looking at you guys a blog
site before we started this demo and it
looks like you know we're making some
changes to the way that at least with
the hunter the way you like aim with
your bow you could target specific yeah
departure things like yeah so we
actually have had it in a hotspot system
for range characters so you'll notice
sometimes when i was playing 100 i was
getting critical hit and those are
actually it's not just like a random guy
rolling exactly yes you're hitting a
certain part of the bottom yep and the
same thing actually applies to towers
and melee cares actually done a lot of
work to make just the combat feel more
of an oh crap it was like when I
shouldn't be talking I know I know
playing and talking to my barricade and
I'll hear myself we've done a lot of
work to make the combat feel more
responsive
I can taught him now follow me around I
know I know kind of my way caught him
away bring him back over here where all
the shiny objects are one he's got so
much help are you guys attacking him at
all today you know you got it you're the
tank you got the big sword oh you got
snotted think we might not make it
Oh died and watch with other people are
things are looking dire 15 heroes now
the weather bugs have dug in there's
only five enemies left though maybe they
can take them out the lower idol is
under attack needs only against bad yeah
we're really close are you gonna make it
it's like it's the it's the mini-boss
and the to the tube with the bugs it
looks like that's all that's left all
the draft as long as he doesn't turn on
to this main thing I think we got it
she's got it gotta freezin nice nice he
doesn't know what's up there you go
there you go so the elemental system
really comes in handy can actually build
some cars back period Oh as the it's the
butt slam as your night character can
you walk at all or is it just yet okay
blocking actually is the old reason why
I'm still alive it's active and it's
actually much more effective than in the
first game okay oh crap careful the butt
slam is gonna take out the tower it's a
little he'll find any boxes so little
health on the tighter well did the
Buddha bugs actually deal damage oh nice
thank God nice the weather bugs don't
deal damage thing thank you but I do
make them take more damage alright
Philippa on that triumphant note I think
that will bring our demonstration do a
close you guys mentioned the working in
pre-alpha right now and you get land any
beta plans you can share with uh we're
playing the soft launch sometime this
spring so stay tuned alright well thank
you so much for stopping by and thank
you folks at home for watching I maximum
the gate for gamespot com saying see you
next time
you